we've just got a house together in  Dallas and he has his backpack and we're  go now that Bachelorette star Jojo  Fletcher has settled into her new home  with fiance Jordan Rogers it seems the  couple is enjoying all the best Dallas  has to offer  the pair made an appearance at the bud  light party convention on Thursday and  it was a Fletcher family affair Jojo  shared this hilarious video to snapchat  we kind of can't get over how awesome  JoJo's parents are just look at them  breaking it down the crew rocked out to  a performance by Jason Derulo and  country star Brett Eldredge who shared  this take posing with the reality stars  and congratulated them on their  engagement in the caption